hello everyone I'm pleased to announce
my new tour for
2024 beginning in early February and
running through June Tammy and I an
assortment of special guests are going
to visit 51 cities in the US you can
find out more information about this on
my website
jordanbpeterson.com as well as accessing
all relevant ticketing information I'm
going to use the tour to walk through
some of the ideas I've been working on
my forthcoming book out November 2024 we
who wrestle with God I'm looking forward
to this I'm thrilled to be able to do it
again and I'll be pleased to see all of
you again soon
bye-bye we have to worry about our air
land and water for sure 10 billion
people on the planet there were 1
billion in 1800 2 billion in 1900 4
billion in 1985 8 billion in 2022 and
will Peak out at 10 billion by 2073
according to the L we've never had that
circumstance before Jordan we're going
going to have to find ways to live
differently more inclusively and more
sustainably while we continue to
[Music]
grow hello everyone today I have the
privilege of talking to Mr Terrence
Keeley Terry was a speaker at the recent
art conference in London in the business
stream he's an expert on so-called ESG
investing of which he is quite skeptical
perhaps the world's most foremost
skeptic All Things Considered we talked
about the idea of ethical investing
exactly what that means the perils
pitfalls and Promises of pursuing
so-called ethical investing strategies
uh investment strategies we talked about
the necessity of formulating a positive
vision for the future financial and
otherwise and and delved into the
details uh of the 2008 financial crisis
and the role played in that by the
blindness willful and otherwise of
people who were responsible for managing
the world's money welcome to the
discussion so Terry let's start this out
with uh I'd like to ask you some
questions about your experience at ARK
maybe you could tell everybody watching
and listening what you experienced there
and what the consequences for you
generally were with regard to the
conference as a whole before we turn our
attention to the spefic specific topics
that you addressed in the panel that you
participated in in London well as you
remember Jordan we met just this summer
at Heather Higgins home and we ended up
having a very interesting conversation
on the role of business and finance in
fashioning a better world and uh you
kindly extended an invitation to me to
be part of an ESG panel but what I
didn't realize in accepting that
invitation it was that I was going to be
in the company of 1,500 wonderful people
from how many 60 countries I can't
remember 70 72 countries 72 countries uh
with a very like mind and that is how
can we tell a better story uh and get
Humanity on a better path for the very
severe challenges that lie in the
decades ahead and I I have to say uh you
know through you and to all of the other
organizers I just have a profound sense
of gratitude um I felt frankly like I
was coming home I live in a world where
I have to be more careful
with you about your pronouns and you
have to be with me about my religious
beliefs uh and yet I found in London uh
that I was with many like-minded people
who share a reverence for God and a
reverence for Humanity and a and a great
desire to keep the planet on the right
path a sustainable path but a path of
growth and greater
inclusivity um and the way you and and
Philippa and others brought together the
themes of art of music poetry religion
uh as well as business themes uh
political themes uh it was just a huge
privilege for me uh in in many ways and
I don't know what the status is for many
of your listeners but it's difficult to
be a conservative in America today you
don't really have a political party you
don't really have a a common home to to
to go to and at Ark in London I felt I
was with a global community of of like
Believers Jordan and uh and I came
through very very hopeful two weeks
earlier I had been at Mitt Romney's E2
conference I don't know if you know but
Mitt Romney's sponsors an annual events
in in Park City uh E2 stands for
enthusiasts and experts and I felt
similarly there that you know uh again
men and women of Faith uh who have a
very uh deep concern for Humanity a very
deep concern for the trajectory that
we're on uh but have Solutions and ideas
for for A Better Way Forward for as I
wrote in that article for Real Clear
Politics a better story um maybe I can
share a very personal story already
which is that uh my niece who went to
Stanford and graduated the 4.0 is one of
many thousands if not to say hundreds of
thousands of individuals uh who are in
their mid-20s who don't want to have
children Jordan don't want to have
children CU how could you imagine
bringing children into a world when on
January 1st 2050 the whole world's going
to blow up because of climate change how
how how could we be so Thoughtless and
so to have a a clear narrative a much
better narrative about how our future is
not disastrous our future is up to us
we're going to get the globe that we
deserve and quite candidly with greater
mindfulness it's going to be the
greatest possible human achievement ever
and so that's how I felt coming out of
London and how I felt with the great
program that you and your colleagues put
together do you do you think this takes
us off our topic a bit but I'm going to
go there
anyways I mean you stressed two things
that struck you when you were at the art
conference and that that was that you
were surrounded by people of faith and
you could read that religiously to some
degree but you could also read it as
being surrounded by people who are
willing to have the courage to put
forward a positive vision of the future
CU that's a form of Faith too and it's
very important for people who are
watching and listening to understand
that you can't take a step into the
future without faith because you can't
predict with anything approximating
certainty what's going to happen as you
move forward and so you have to adopt an
attitude a priority that sees you
through regardless of what happens and
you can adopt an attitude of corrosive
cynicism and bitterness and pessimism
and defend yourself that way and there
are times when that's appropriate but as
a general stance towards the world it
tends to be counterproductive and it's
also the case that um what a fragmented
or misplaced Faith religious Faith even
tends to seems to have as a consequence
the development of something like an
anti-human stance as things that aren't
human like nature itself become
worshiped instead of what's properly put
first and foremost and there is a
remarkable concordance I would say
between
the religious belief that each person is
a Divine locus of being let's say and
and made in the image of God and a
pro-human stance and one of the things
that's really terrified me about the
environmentalist movement which purports
to be about the sanctity and security of
the planet is easily transformed into
something that is clearly and demonst
anti-human like I've watched in absolute
open-mouthed amazement over the last 10
years as the greens and the radical
leftists when push comes to shove
immediately demonstrate their
willingness to sacrifice the poor to
their planetary salvation delusions and
it's so interesting he because in
principle the left has being the party
that puts forward the demand for
compassion towards the marginalized and
the oppressed economically and otherwise
but man when you stack up the oppressed
and margin ized against the hypothetical
interests of the planet as such the
lefties will sacrifice the poor in a
tenth of a second and they do that not
least with their insistence that energy
costs have to Skyrocket and consumption
come down which to me is tantamount
saying when consumption comes down the
poor starve that's a necessary
consequence of decreased consumption and
anyone who thinks otherwise is either
willfully blind or ignorant Beyond any
what would you say any morally
acceptable uh degree so all right so so
it was very it was very let let let let
me take a moment to respond to that
though Jordan because it's absolutely
clear that everyone implicitly or
explicitly has a religious belief for
some people the religious belief is that
there is no religious belief but that
then becomes its own religion that is to
say some form of massive uh uh moral
relativism becomes what in fact what
they worshiped I stood in awe uh of you
speaking on the stage at a couple of
times about Jacob's Latter in the Book
of Job and you know Jordan what's
fascinating about you and I know this is
your podcast but priests and I I'm I
come from a Catholic background I worked
for Pope Francis I co-chaired at the
Vatican Financial Reform Commission I
have quite a quite a Catholic background
but priests cannot put people in pews
and yet you can fill the O2 Arena with
tens of thousands of young men to talk
about the Book of Job and talk about
Jacob's Latter and talk about the uphill
struggle as being the moral struggle of
our times uh uh I just congratulate you
and your colleagues and I know you give
a lot of credit to those around you as
well uh for just being able Jordan to
enunciate this message in a way where it
resonates to those who are genuinely
lost to those who are genuinely looking
for a a road map of how to have a better
and more productive life
and I I I I I want to establish early on
this call I'm not a climate denier uh I
do believe that there are human
influences that are uh very much putting
our land our air and our water at risk
by the way the planet has never had 8
billion inhabitants before we're about
to be 10 billion inhabitants we're going
to have to find ways to behave much more
sustainably but I was looking through my
book of notes from from the AR
conference and one of the things that I
wrote down is it's not the climate deny
it's the tradeoff deniers and even in
loto C in the papal encyclical written
by Pope Francis on the climate crisis he
is very clear Jordan very clear that
there are tradeoffs that we need to have
more Prosperity there are too many
people that are left behind the vast
majority of human beings still use less
electricity than one refrigerator uses
in a year in the west we need to find
ways to improve access improve AA
ability improve abundance of and we've
just finished this cop 28 conference
this morning as you know and you know
they've come off and finally been able
to say Let's do let's phase out fossil
fuels but they're very quick right
they're very quick to add that this must
be done in a just way well if it's done
in a just way the only way we're going
to be able to get ourselves off of
fossil fuels is by massively increasing
Nuclear by massively increasing some
other sources and that is not plausible
from now to 2050 we we are simply going
to be continuing to utilize this mix of
fossil fuels uh that we're dependent on
for reasons of justice for reasons of
human need for reasons of human
necessity and as you pointed out and
others at the conference if you look
around the globe the wealthiest
countries are the ones that actually
have the cleanest Energy Mix so we must
uh prioritize uh continued economic
growth this is the Mantra that I come to
in my book repeatedly yes we need more
economic growth but it needs to be more
inclusive and it does need to be more
sustainable and I am a member of the the
church that says let's optimize between
these various trade-offs growth and
cleanliness and sustainability there are
trade-offs and we're going to have to
navigate them it's multivariable
calculus it's not as easy as the only
thing that matters is Net Zero by 2050
it's not the only thing that matters
many things matter well well that only
thing that matters narrative I've been
I've been thinking that through in some
detail and
so part of what we're facing on the
pathological culture War front is
oversimplification that occurs for two
reasons and the first reason is purely
factual is that there are human effects
on the environment some of which are
deleterious um I was struck most
particularly when investigating such
effects of on the effects of
unrestricted um Coastal fishing on fish
stocks because I think that's something
we've done particularly disastrously
there's a variety of problems like that
but the important thing is there's a
variety and that the uh the solutions to
those problems are actually well they're
multi-dimensional and complex and you
can collapse all that into a single
Theory which is that all the there's one
fundamental environmental emergency
that's climate related and that can be
attributed more or less solely to carbon
dioxide and so the Temptation there is
to take this overwhelming complexity on
the factual side and reduce it to the
kind of simple Mantra that anyone can
Master really in about 15 minutes and
then you're done with that whole problem
it's like well no the important thing is
climate and the solution is carbon
dioxide reductions like now now the
benefit to you is that you don't have to
think anymore but there's an additional
benefit to the oversimplification which
I think is even more
nefarious and it's analogous to the
oversimplification that's part and
parcel of the victim victimizer
narrative you know if you view the world
through a lens of power and you assume
that every human relationship can be
understood in terms of victim and
victimizer then all you have to do as a
moral agent is claim your allyship with
the vi victim and you've solved your
moral problem the same thing applies on
the environmental front is once you've
established that carbon dioxide is the
villain then you can make yourself not
only a moral agent but something akin to
the Redeemer himself by merely
proclaiming your uh what would you say
your moral commitment to the goal of
carbon dioxide reduction and so you
eliminate having to think in the factual
world and you eliminate actually having
to do all the work that a companies
genuine moral effort by swallowing the
environmentalist narrative and then
there's even a darker part of it as far
as I'm concerned and this is where
things go from merely ignorant and blind
to outright malevolent which is that
once you've identified the problem and
the moral solution you can also take aim
at anyone who hypothetically stands in
the way and you can demonize them and as
a consequence of your demonization you
can you can let the worst elements in
your char character have full
reign in relationship to how you treat
those people and you certainly see that
with the victim victimizer narrative
that's being played out with Hamas at
the moment the Jews are the victimizers
the Palestinians are the victims and so
that means the Jews are properly subject
to whatever punishment you feel inclined
to meet out it's the same with those who
hypothetically are compromising the
environment and so it's such an ugly
mess he because it's oversimplification
Factor
it's ridiculous reductionism on the
moral side and then it's the provision
of a world that allows your desire for
vengeful resentment driven hypothetical
Justice to have full Reign Over those
you deem to be enemies of you in the
planet a very very toxic combination and
so that's the sort of thing it's that
combination I believe that actually
presents the apocalyptic danger and not
whatever other problems severe as they
are that might confront this on the
Environ confront us on the environmental
side well I I have to give again credit
to the arc organizers because I think
you had the most definitive speaker
Steven kunan talk about the science and
when I'm in uh let's I I just spoke at a
climate Symposium at Harvard two weeks
ago you you know Jordan and I always try
to present facts calmly there have been
five mass extinction events on planet
Earth in the last 500 million years
every single one of them were caused by
the planet cooling too quickly that's
how we lost the dinosaurs as you know uh
you can actually give a Litany of
Statistics some of which I've gotten
from bjor lomborg over the years from
from the Copenhagen uh uh Think Tank the
polar bear population is five times what
it was 50 years ago total sea rise in
the last 100 years has only been 23 cm
23 cm meaning meanwhile a lot of these
atols in these island nations they've
grown 123 CM many of them are actually
in better position than they were uh we
are having less violent storms but I I
think the the Steven Konan argument
which is really an important one is yes
human beings have an impact yes carbon
dioxide matters but it matters at such a
small level relative to many other
factors that are actually impacting the
climate many of which we don't
understand so where I take that and I I
try to um not oversimplify the climate
mess but I always say that it's a
complicated two-part problem one it's a
collective action problem that is to say
uh the greenhouse gases that are emitted
by three countries only China India and
Russia right now are two and a half
times that admitted by the entire North
American continent and European Union
combined so until India China and Russia
are as serious about greenhouse gases as
the rest of us are supposed to be let's
not kid ourselves we still have a
greenhouse gas problem and then the
other one is the latoo C Pope Francis
this is a multivariable calculous
problem uh what we have is people who
are denying that there are trade-offs
let's recognize that there are
trade-offs and let's have a calm uh uh
inclusive fact-based conversation about
what's the best thing to do I I brought
a prop today this is a a plastic bottle
right it has water in it well so I was
telling the crew before we started this
BT today Jordan has onethird the amount
of plastic that had in it 3 years ago
that's not because of an ESG regulation
that's because it's cheaper to make it
with less plastic and you can do it with
less plastic this is the kind of
progress that is being made because we
are more mindful consumers are changing
their investment decisions we are seeing
people that want to have greater Su
sustainability we can look at Patagonia
this company that now only does clothes
that if you bring them back they repair
them for you patagonia's products are
flying off the shelves people want to
have a sustainable future this is one of
the reasons why we can be optimistic
about Humanity's future Jordan and I I
don't downplay human influences we have
to worry about our air land and water
for sure 10 billion people on the planet
there were 1 billion in 1800 2 billion
in 1900 4 billion in 1985 8 billion in
2022 and will Peak out at 10 billion by
2073 according to the lanet how are we
all going to stay here on this planet
together allowing everyone to achieve
their full potential we're going to have
to live differently we're also going to
have to live in an era of of Aging uh in
2035 there will be more people over the
age of 65 than under the age of 18 we've
never had that circumstance before
Jordan we're going to have to find ways
to live differently more inclusively and
more sustainably while we continue to
grow and all of that is possible I wrote
a book on it and I'm just so incredibly
optimistic about Humanity's future and
the AR conference really helped un for
me underscore a lot of those themes well
and so one of the things that that we
could derive from let's say your
discussion of Patagonia is that these
new ways that we're going to be required
to find to live need to be offered to
people as an invitation and not forced
on them and so here's one of the things
that happened in the aftermath of the
art conference that I found extremely
interesting and so we had quite a range
of speakers and the and a quite a range
of approach from speakers and political
attitude and what happened was that the
speakers who were the most political and
who were the most tendentious and
accusatory let's say in their approach
produced the speeches that got by
thinking is that John Howard who are you
thinking ofy McCarthy okay yeah Kevin M
particularly this isn't an insult you
know he's a politician and but okay but
but what happens it's so interesting to
see is because the talks that really
offered a Invitational metaphysical
Vision got exponentially more views in
the aftermath of the art conference
that's yeah yeah and so so and so but
but I think this is very much well worth
noting is that as you point out people
do understand quite broadly that we have
to live in something approximating
harmony with the broad natural
environment and people are interested in
finding ways to do that but if they're
forced or manipulated into doing that
which I think is it tends to be the
approach of organizations like the wef
and the UN and even the European Union
to a large degree if they're forced to
do that or connived into it or even
nudged into it which is a very
manipulative way of going about things
they're going to resist they're going to
fight back and we're not going to get
anywhere whereas if people are invited
and and and offered an alternative that
they can undertake voluntarily the
probability that they're going to first
attend and and then comply is
extraordinarily High not comply that's
not the right word but but participate
you know you see this in Psychotherapy
it's a psychotherapeutic truism is that
I uh if you are setting up a situation
where someone is pursuing positive
behavioral change
they have to determine the direction of
that change and come to develop and
accept the strategies voluntarily or all
they do is kick back in all sorts of
ways that are counterproductive and
produce resistance and but it was so
interesting to see that unfold at the
arc conference because the speakers who
were Visionary and Invitational had by
far the biggest effect and they really
set the tone for the conference too and
so we really tried to learn that attent
that that lesson right this has to be an
invitation that could bring us to to our
discussion of esgs do you want out let
let let I just love to give an
exclamation point to some of the points
you're making though Jordan because you
you worry about a top-down solution and
there's every reason for you to worry
about top down Solutions we see it right
now I don't know if you know but clean
energy stocks this year are down 25%
while the stock market is up 25% we've
been forcing so much money into some
Clean Energy Solution windmills off the
coast of Maine and others that are
simply not working out similarly all
these incentives to go buy electric
vehicles are not working so there's
General Motors Ford stantis yes they're
worried about a UAW strike but they're
even more worried about the fact that
California is mandating them to create
electric vehicles that people are not
buying Jordan people are not buying
those cars so what are we going to do
have a bunch of EVS out in parking lots
that nobody's willing to buy and think
that we're solving our global uh climate
crisis we not so there is this danger as
you say as you enunciate of top-down
solutions that are not being met by
bottom up and this is the the beauty of
the market you know Friedrich Hayek has
a lot to say to us still you know I was
thinking as I Was preparing for the show
this morning that God himself could not
create a better system than the free
markets and the reason is that the free
markets consist of billions and billions
of decisions that are being made by
consumers out of their own free will
that are ultimately going to drive where
we're going to end up and it's so
important to remember that that that
that consumers attitudes change
consumers are going to want to have for
example Louis vuon is right now
designing all of these new uh luxury
leather goods that are made out of
mushrooms so that they can say this most
this next very luxurious bag is carbon
negative and I promise you they're going
to sell a lot of those bags to people
out there who really want to be able to
say look I have a carbon negative bag uh
the the the the beauty of the free
markets uh governed by men and women of
conscience who are are mindful with
their their their consumption patterns
and investment patterns and that's why I
say mindfulness we're going to get the
world we deserve either in this world or
the next we greater mindfulness will
lead to Greater outcomes um uh but we
should let the markets let the markets
work because they are better at at at
delivering the future than anybody who's
guessing what the future will be we're
going to have way too many
EVS start off the new year with balance
of nature fruits and veggies they're a
great way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day of the New Year balance of
nature uses an advanced cold vacuum
process that encapsulates fruits and
vegetables into Whole Food supplements
without sacrificing their natural
antioxidants the capsules are completely
void of additives fillers extracts
synthetics pesticides or added sugar the
only thing in balance of Nature's fruit
and veggie capsules are well fruits and
veggies right now not only will you get
35% off your first order you'll now get
a free fiber and spice supplement as
well balance of Nature's fiber and spice
supplement is a revolutionary fiber
drink with a unique blend of 12 spices
and Whole Foods there's never been an
easier way to make sure you're getting
your daily dose of fruits and vegetables
experience balance of nature for
yourself today go to balance of
nature.com and use promo code Jordan for
35% off your first order as a preferred
customer plus get a free bottle of fiber
and spice that's balanceof nature.com
promo code Jordan for 35% off your first
preferred order plus a free bottle of
fiber and
spice let's delve into that a little bit
so the the technical reason for that so
that everybody watching and listening
understands when people promote the free
market that can be an ideological
promotion or it can be a an observation
of sheer computational power so imagine
that you're you're trying to make
pricing decisions and purchasing
decisions which you have to do all the
time in this world when you're trading
one thing off against another you could
imagine either that you set up a system
just think about it computationally you
could set up a situation where there are
literally millions or even billions of
local computers Gathering data about
local circumstances making
tradeoffs with regard to everything
that's available to them in terms of
data in that local environment and then
communicating in a network Fashion To
indicate Trends and future and future
probabilities so what needs to be
produced for example or you could
replace that by a single computer or 10
of them that are trying to gather all of
that information with no eyes on the
ground
relying on their hypothetical
ideological expertise and that's the
central planning model it's like why the
hell would you exchange billions of
distributed computers with sensory
apparatus on the ground for a handful of
centralized computers that can't even in
principle have access to the proper data
it's a Preposterous claim it's an absurd
claim and it's not like there's
something magic about the free market
except for the fact that it's an optimiz
system of distributed computation and
there is no replacing that with
centralized View and you do get this
problem that you just described I mean I
think with regards to EVS I've wondered
this for a long time electric vehicles
is like we know perfectly well not least
because of what happened to California
when they announced that everybody
couldn't plug in their electric cars at
the same time because the grid didn't
have the capacity it's like I've been
wondering well why are we being enjoined
to buy electric cars when they when we
don't have the grid power to to uh
recharge them and then I thought oh well
if the plan is actually like the C40
plan which is the plan put forward by a
Consortium of large cities if the plan
is to reduce automobile ownership by 95%
anyways it doesn't matter if you force
people to buy electric cars that no one
wants and that we won't be able to
recharge because the bloody plan is for
people not to have cars at all anyway
and that's a that's well right and
that's such a terrible plan because
cars there's very little difference
between a car and freedom and wealth it
gives you such an unbelievable range of
options at any given time ridiculously
efficient use of private time and
anybody who objects to that I think is
immediately to be viewed with extreme
suspicion especially if they're trying
to implement top-down compulsory
controls you know one of our principles
at ARC is no policy that requires
compulsion is optimized there's a
mistake it somewhere you know that gets
tricky when you're dealing with
criminals you know because sometimes
people are in situations where they
won't behave socially or in a
psychologically in a manner that
reflects psychological Integrity without
compulsion but most of the time the rule
of thumb has to be if I have to force
you to do something I'm putting forward
the proposition improperly at minimum
improperly well I I I as as you're
speaking you know uh and I I'll talk
about a couple different books today if
I'm allowed to but one that's that that
really did uh reach reach me uh it was
written by rag Rajan who's a professor
of Finance at the University of Chicago
and it's called the third pillar and
what the thesis that R Rajan has he's
also the former Chief Economist of the
IMF and former governor of The Reserve
Bank of India but Jordan what his thesis
is is that societies Thrive when they
have the three primary pillars of
societal good in Balance one is the
markets if if if you don't have markets
you're not driving Prosperity the second
is the state you need good you need you
you need good government I I don't know
about you but I like getting my driver's
license on time I like it when the stop
lights actually work we need good
government the government that governs
least is not necessarily the one that
governs best and I think Canada is an
example of that but the third one is
actually Community or Civic society and
what the the the thesis that that that R
Rajan puts out I think very effectively
is that if you have uh societies that
have either one of those out of kilter
where where where markets are too strong
then then we run into environmental
problems or we run into issues of
distribution we we do have externalities
negative externalities in markets that
need to be corrected by proper
government but the role of community and
the role of Nos and the role of the uh
uh volunteer sector the role of faith in
a community the role is equally
important if societies have any one of
those missing they are not in optimal
balance they tend towards crony
capitalism which is this topic that Paul
Marshall spoke about as you know at ARC
or they they tend towards
inefficiencies uh you have to have all
three we need markets we need an optimal
State and we need the community thriving
NGO sector Thrive it non for-profits
which we do have in the United States uh
in the United States we could use
slightly better governments this is
where we're where we're falling down uh
quite quite candidly you know I I bring
up Paul Marshall um I wrote two articles
after um after the AR conference and one
was inspired by Paul Marshall but not in
the way that he thinks uh he actually
spoke from the stage about the negative
impact of uber as if it had you know
demolished uh uh the lives of many
Livery drivers which it has it has
interrupted the lives of many Livery
drivers but Jordan it has vastly
expanded the market for Livery driving
around the world there have been 4.2
billion Uber Uber ride since it was
first and the number of markets there
are 5.5 million Uber drivers that turn
on and off when they want to go to work
this was a wonderful Market Innovation
but it's what EF Schumacher calls
creative destruction markets need to be
destructive just as they need to be uh
creative in in in order to maintain that
efficiency there's going to be
disruptions that take place Uber is a
good disruption um I was talking to
Philip about this afterwards he said
well it helps if you're Paul Marshall
because you always have a driver waiting
for you uh those Schmucks like me that
come to Phoenix and need to find a way
to get in from the airport I'd rather
just do it on my Uber app so um but but
well the advantage to the market too is
that it allows those disruptive forces
to operate in a comparatively at a
comparatively micro level I mean there's
still radical transformations in market
economies but the problem with the
centralized economy is that they're so
St fgy and blind
that adaptation only occurs in
catastrophic fits whereas in a in a
dynamic Market there can be local small
revolutions that are continuous and like
the way of of conceptualizing it
technically is that the environment
transforms at a rate that slightly
exceeds our adaptation so there's always
unexpected things happening as a
consequence of the action of reality
itself and then we have to fight to keep
up and we're always a little slow on the
uptake and so the adaptation process is
can be can be disruptive but the wider
the distribution of responsibility for
adaptation the larger variety of of
revolutionary adaptations that can be on
offer and the smaller and more matched
they are to the environmental
transformation they can be and so you
know it is frightening when you see uh a
novel technological move forward like
uber which does disrupt Industries and
cause a certain number of people grief
but that's much better than refusing to
adapt to the necessity for change and
then have having to un involuntarily
undergo a cataclysmic form of
readaptation I mean that's really what
happened when the Soviet Union collapsed
it was that so many things had gone
wrong that the only solution was that
the whole system had to die well that's
that that's that's an obvious evidence
of market failure when huge things die
small things didn't die fast enough
that's really the rule of thumb so I
think I think there's so many
interesting lessons too right now Jordan
from Ai and from the effective altruism
movement uh many things that we can
learn about the governance issues that
just came out of open Ai and we I I
don't want to go down that rabbit hole
but a lot of them again uh I think are
are highlight the the principal points
we making markets are important let
Capital move freely uh uh let Let There
Be Innovation as you know the whole idea
between open AI was to have an
open-source platform that everyone was
contributing to make it altruistic so
that it could be done in a good way and
then they found well we still need
billions of dollars how are we going to
raise the billions of dollars to create
the computational capacity that Ai and
chat gbt really requires and they knew
they had to have that in a for-profit
arm if they did not have that in a
for-profit arm they would not have found
the capital so so important lessons I
think uh uh yes uh of course we need to
be mindful but there's no way to build
the world that we want to build where
the needs and aspirations of the
trillions of people yet to come because
by the way if you actually look at where
uh Homo sapiens sapiens are in the
normal course there are trillions of
human beings yet to be born this is the
William McAllister uh arguments that you
probably what we owe the future a famous
philosopher from uh Oxford University
that you need to have on your on your
show if you haven't had him on yet uh um
and and and so and this is something
that the pope speaks about very very
eloquently also in l c which is that we
do have in many ways Jordan we do have
responsibilities to Future Generations
uh and we need to think how often do you
think about your grandchildren how often
do you think about your grandchildren's
grandchildren do you care about them do
you love them is is the life of your
great great great great grandchild any
less important than your life no it's
not so let's go about this process of
thinking how it is that we're going to
create this sustainable planet and I I
spent a little bit of time talking about
um you know the the broad philosophy of
rag Rajan but where I have spent a great
deal of my life and work is in Catholic
Social teaching and I I I'd love to come
to Catholic Social teaching at some
point on this uh podcast because as I
say it it happens to be extraordinarily
resident and pertinent for the times we
live in not because it's Catholic it
just happens to be Catholic it's
actually about 150 years old and I think
the broad principles of human dignity
subsidiarity which you spoke about very
eloquently from the stage responsibility
personal responsibility uh and then
solidarity the third principle of
Catholic Social teaching which is that
we are our brothers and sisters Keepers
there are too many people Jordan that
cannot take care of themselves and it is
the respon responsibility of the strong
to help the weak it is the
responsibility for those of us who have
more capacities and more capabilities to
give that hand up to those who do not
have it that is Catholic Social teaching
and what's interesting is that
subsidiarity argument you know turns out
the Declaration of Independence is right
all men and women are created equal
they're obviously in the image of God
and they are entitled to a life of
Liberty uh and and the pursuit of
happiness their own ful fulfillment but
the simple fact of the matter is that
that cannot be achieved without people
taking personal responsibility and
families taking responsibilities for
their own families and then communities
beyond that uh uh that is how the system
is going to work subsidiarity and
solidarity there are going to live in
constant tension we're never going to
have them resolved there's always going
to be somebody else who needs to be
helped there's always going to be
somebody else who needs to have more
responsibility and that is that struggle
uphill that you spoke so so eloquently
about uh time and again at
ARK starting a business can be tough
especially knowing how to run your
online storefront thanks to Shopify it's
easier than ever Shopify is the global
Commerce platform that helps you sell at
every stage of your business from the
launch your online shop stage all the
way to the did we just hit a million
orders stage Shopify is there to help
you grow our marketing team uses Shopify
every day to sell our merchandise and we
love how easy it is to add more items
ship products and track conversions
Shopify helps you turn browsers into
buyers with the internet's best
converting check checkout up to 36%
better compared to other leading
Commerce platforms no matter how big you
want to grow Shopify gives you
everything you need to take control and
take your business to the next level
sign up for a $1 per month trial period
at shopify.com
jbp go to shopify.com jbp now to grow
your business no matter what stage
you're at that's shopify.com
[Music]
jbp so the the idea of responsibility
for future Generations let let's wander
into the to the Catholic Social teaching
domain for a moment so I spent a lot of
time recently writing this book we who
wrestle with God and one of the chapters
in that book deals with the story of
Abraham so Abraham is portrayed as the
father of of Nations and so my sense is
that the story of Abraham contains it
within it the seeds of what would you
say it contains within it a
representation of what it means to live
in the light of Eternity so imagine that
you could adopt an
ethos that set you up in the best
possible manner to increase the
probability that your children would
survive and thrive okay but but then
let's extend that so because that's not
sufficient and you could even make an
evolutionary biology argu in this
direction you want to develop an ethos
that not only increases the probability
that you will have children and that
your children will Thrive and survive
but that establishes a pattern that they
imitate that increases the probability
that their children and their gr and
their children's children will Thrive
and survive so it's an ethos that has to
have a
multigenerational that has to have
multigenerational implication okay so
that's exactly what Abraham does now and
and that's the the the manner in which
that's to be done is actually laid out
in the narrative so the first thing that
happens that's very very interesting
because it has to do with material
satiation at the beginning of the story
Abraham is already he's already in the
arms of the of the infantile Utopia
right because Abraham has Rich parents
and he's privileged and he has
everything material that anyone could
ever want and yet this voice comes to
him it's the voice of his ancestors and
God and it says
go out away from what is secure and have
the adventure of your life and there's a
call that's the calling and Abraham
attends to that calling and moves out
into the world to cataclysmic end right
because he encounters famine and slavery
and the connivance of the aristocrats to
steal his wife and battles with his
in-laws and like the whole terrible
array of potential catastrophes in life
present themselves to Abraham but he
maintains a sacrificial attitude right
that's that's emphasized throughout the
text because every time Abraham embarks
on a new adventure start something new
he rekindles his affiliation with what
is highest and moves forward in faith
and that's presented as part of a
multigenerational vision and so one of
the things that I find very exciting
about the potential Union of something
like evolutionary biology and deep
theology is the idea that if we oriented
ourselves properly to the highest good
which is by the way the message that's
in The Sermon on the Mount we would see
in that good the manifestation of the
pathway that would enable us to live in
a way that would Ure that respect for
multigenerational continuity that you
just spoke about as the so of
sustainability and so what that means is
that it's the adoption of individual
ethical responsibility in the highest
manner that constitutes the proper
Pathway to sustainability and not top
down manipulation of the political
economic and social systems to bring
about some form of of of what plans
stability which we can't do right we
can't do that no I mean you said the
mere fact that you said earlier it's
like if you look at China and Russia and
India first of all we have absolutely no
right to tell them that they can't take
the same Pathway to wealth that we took
and that was going to involve the use of
coal and it's going to involve the use
of fossil fuels and we might as well
bloody well just get used to that cuz
that's going to happen and then maybe
out in the Western countries we could be
laying the groundwork for a nuclear
Revolution and and and and show the
pathway forward for these countries that
will have to transition through fossil
fuel but there's no bloody way we're
going to be able to do that by imposing
Our Idiot utopian views on China and
Russia and India they're just going to
tell us to go to hell which is what they
should do well I I I'm I'm thinking of
your your Abraham's story you know
Jordan and just the importance of it and
focus on future generations and one of
the lines that you used repeatedly in
London which has been inscribed into my
brain is about tilting the world towards
heaven and not towards hell how do we
tilt do you know there's a lot that we
can't do but how do we you know if the
Arc of humanity bends towards Justice to
what degree can we help get that Justice
Arc going in in the right direction and
uh another book that I wanted to give a
shout out to that I know you have read
and so many people have is pan Lor's
most recent book best things first and
you know let's just be very clear in
this book Boran lomborg points out 12
different policies uh five of which are
related to health two of which are
related to nutrition one of education
and four of which are economic that
would cost $36 billion a year in a
global economy that has 100 12 trillion
dollar in 120 depending on PP purchasing
power par but less than onethird of
1% would actually save 4.2 Million Lives
and would generate a higher GDP of $1.1
trillion doar particularly in subsaharan
Africa where this growth is most needed
and these are simple tuberculosis
malaria ending neglected tropical
diseases agricultural abundance you just
look through you know I I I would I you
know one of the things I'd love to do is
give a copy of that book to literally
every single policy maker that is to say
every single Abraham on Earth saying
look here are things that we can do
right now they're very practical ending
neglecting tropical diseases uh doing
eprocurement uh so that there's a a much
greater transparency free trade we're
all against right now everyone's
clamping down on free trade no free
trade benefits Humanity overall we we've
got to continue to find ways where we
can trade in accordance with comparative
advantage this will in fact lift these
billions of people who are not yet
within the cycle of abundance not yet in
in in in free of energy insecurity I
it's another topic that we touched upon
uh in London but that we need to return
to there are three billion human beings
on Earth that live in energy poverty
they can't turn on the lights what they
want more than anything there not air
conditioning they actually would like to
have a lamp to read their books at night
they can't even read their books so so
these types of B lomberg policies these
types of I have many of them in in my
book as well as a a concept I called
exemplars of Hope very huge Returns on
on on investment some of those
Investments have to be done human to
human uh and I I always say you know
Jordan there is no marginal tax rate
that gets you to heaven if your if your
earnings are taxed at 100% there's
there's no moral you know paying them
yes it's legal but that doesn't get you
to heaven to get to heaven it will be by
your works alone what you do and how you
care for those who are most in need and
how you can do that at a societal level
which I believe you do with your podcast
which I believe you do with your
teaching I was listening to one of your
Joe Rogan uh conversations recently and
you were talking with joy absolute Joy
about how people come to you and talk
about how their lives have been
transformed because of the type of
self-help advice that you've given to
them I look at these things much more
from a what is an economic um solution
as you know I've written this book on
ESG I'm sure we'll get into ESG a little
bit I'm Pro I'm probably the number one
critic on the face of the Earth at ESG
not because of what it's trying to do I
believe that ESG was born of something
very good that you know I think there's
a lot of great intentions out there I
don't I really don't want to discourage
or or uh uh uh dis disdained the the
intentions of even people who are out
there protesting uh uh for for for zeroc
carbon uh emissions their intentions are
good Jordan we need to work with those
intentions but what will actually work
what practically will create a globe of
Greater economic growth that is
simultaneously more inclusive welcoming
in those who have not yet had the great
benefits that they need and should have
and have every god-given right to have
just like you and I do to have the types
of material abundance where they can
pursue all their other dreams as well as
sustainability sustainability is not
going away uh we're going we're going to
you talk about the fisheries and how
much Cod is off the shore if we're not
going to be mindful about these things
we're screwed we're going to be screwed
so so so so uh I I I make that case but
I can talk about homelessness I can talk
about solutions for recidivism I can
talk about solutions for uh infant uh uh
and and mother nutrition there are
solutions out there that just like Bjorn
lorg points out in his book are not that
expensive relative to the huge benefits
that we can get from them and this is
something let's do two let's do two
things let's let's wander through the
ESG territory so maybe you can
illuminate my guests as to as to exactly
what ESG means and why it came about and
then why you're you're leery about it
and then let's turn to a discussion of
solutions so I'll let you go ahead with
ESG to begin with educate people to
begin with because it's it's not easy
for people to understand even what ESG
is so the the truth of the matter is
that the environmental social and
governance movement the ESG movement
which is all the rage could not be
understood without the context that's
provided by the United Nations and
everything that has happened since the
second world war so it's a story I need
to tell so as you probably remember at
the end of the second world war Elanor
Roosevelt worked together for 42 43
Nations and they devised the universal
Declaration of Human Rights and this was
a very utopic document Jordan that said
that every human being is entitled to to
to obviously to Freedom there's a whole
range of of of inalienable rights are
talking about but then there are anable
rights they're entitled to food they're
entitled to shelter they're entitled to
education they're so this was quite
something ambitious to do at the end of
the second world war because the world
was devastating well we we we didn't
know how we were going to rebuild the
European
continent Japan was a complete mess and
yet here was this utopic statement of
how Humanity what Humanity should
ultimately be striving for Fast Forward
50 years from the signing of the United
Nations and you have the United Nations
then espousing Millennial development
goals the United Nations sustainable
development goals of which there are now
17 and what happened over the course of
that 50 years is something that is s
insufficiently celebrated since the end
of the second world war till about 2000
the economic transformation of the globe
was beyond anything anyone had possibly
imagined possible the the the actual
material abundance that has actually
emerged since the second world war is
simply unfathomable to your grandparents
or your great-grandparents they would
have no idea so per capita income since
1980 alone went from 25 $0000 to
$122,000 what comes with all of the
growth here's a statistic that I love
Jordan from 1990 until covid
128,000 human Souls escaped abject
poverty every day every day the number
of human beings on the planet that were
living on a191 a day which is how the
World Bank defines abject poverty in
1980 was one out of every two one out of
every two human beings on the planet
Planet struggled to find a meal
struggled to find where are they going
to live would they have any heat
overnight that statistic today is one
out of 10 and of course that transpired
at a time when when population growth
was massive along with all of this
material and economic abundance has come
what always happens greater social
educational and health advancements so
we've had a a circumstance where uh life
expectancy has expanded by 22% over that
same period infant mortality dropped
from 81 out of every uh uh 100,000
births to 25 so infant mortality fell
70% literacy rates massively improved
what happens when Prosperity grows is
other aspects of human existence improve
as well so what happened then and I'm
I'm coming to ESG I'm sorry for the
Prelude but it's necessary to have there
there is no ESG without this material
abundance in in in in
1999 uh and 2000 the United Nations
convened the greatest collection of of
political leaders in history and that
collection included Kings and and and
prime ministers and and they designed
the millennial development goals do you
remember the millennial development
goals the 2000 and and and the
millennial development goals was let's
get rid of poverty completely let's have
uh a k to2 Universal education around
the globe things that were unfathomable
50 years earlier and let's find a way to
make sure that there is greater uh uh
political freedoms uh broadly speaking
what ended up happening though is
continued progress was being made on
those Jordan until about 2005 when Kofi
Anan who was the Secretary General of
the United Nations convened a group of
financiers and he said listen I want
there to be a group of finers that come
up with investment principles that would
help promote these United Nations
sustainable development goals and
Millennial development goals why don't
you very smart people 70 of them he
picked go in a room and come back and
tell me what those principles for
responsible investing are this is where
ESG came from ESG emerged in 2005 with
Kofi andan ringing the bell at the New
York Stock Exchange announcing these
investment principles what were these
investment principles they were a series
of principles relating to environment
mental social and governance factors
that this group of financiers had
assessed could present material risks
material risks if we don't handle these
things well enough they will lead to
financial failure stocks will go down
there there there was so
ESG actually came out of the United
Nations declaration for human rights the
millennial Millennial sustainable and
the millennial development goals and the
sustainable development goals and the
United nation's principles for
responsible investing that first went
public in 2005 today there are more than
6,000 signatories to the United Nations
principles for responsible investment
Jordan uh those institutions
collectively manage 120 trillion dollar
in assets that is to say they they they
manage one half of all the institutional
assets that are available for investment
in the world what are these people doing
well they've come up with a series of
products and ideas and and corporate
resolutions and any number of things
that are intended to highlight various
elements of these environmental social
and governance issues of pertinence to
them so you know we tell the budlight
story right someone decided that it was
very important uh for budlight to expand
its market share they need to be uh
expanding in a Dei sensitive way what
did they do they have a commercial that
was misconceived it pissed off
two-thirds of the people who were
actually drinking their beer uh and
didn't result in any was so the ESG
rules as they have actually been applied
have had a very a very important very
series of unintended consequences that
haven't always been uh well that that
have been deleterious my principal
criticism though of ESG as a finer and
the work that I write about in the book
and the reason why I believe ESG uh has
neither done well nor much good is what
I is what I say that was a Wall Street
Journal oped that I wrote that was read
4.2 million times it hasn't done well
because in actual practice Jordan what
people have done is here's these ESG uh
rules in the S&P 500 which of course is
comprised of the ostensibly the 500 best
companies in in the United States
typically what the ESG uh uh enthusiasts
do is they take out 400 of those and
only invest in 100 of of the remaining
stocks
in actual practice that mean they were
no longer investing in oil and gas they
were no longer investing in what they
regarded as nonvirtuous companies well
this is just so silly this is absolutely
silly the idea of you not owning Exxon
Mobile is going to somehow change the
temperature of the earth is just the
silliest thing imaginable in fact it has
the entire thesis on its head there's
been this concept of socially
responsible investing that has been
around for Cent
I mean for for centuries many people
avoided in investing in in in the slave
trade right many people religious groups
founded absolutely abor but the slave
trade continued didn't it why it
continued because one quarter of
humanity was still willing to invest in
it it turned out as a Bor as it was it
was incredibly lucrative the same thing
is true in modern society there have
been a number of investors likely most
likely religiously based that have
avoided what are called sin stocks the
sin stocks are in four areas gambling Al
Alcohol Tobacco and Firearms so many
religiously
organized religious organizations have
not invested in these for but has that
stopped smoking has that stopped people
drinking has that stopped people from
buying a firearm has that stopped people
from gambling of course it hasn't so the
ESG movement investment movement is
based on the same principle of if I
don't invest in Exxon Mobile somehow the
temperature of the Earth is going to
improve it's pure silliness Jordan it's
pure silliness so I I gave quite a quite
an exposition there where I wanted to
come out is that my criticism of ESG as
an investment movement is not that it
shouldn't be trying to solve the
problems of our times but that it hasn't
it's done exactly the opposite of what
needs to be done and I'm a big proponent
of impact investing and I can give you
literally a hundred examples affordable
housing uh uh uh Dei opportunities for
uh female um uh minority entrepreneurs
that genuinely address some of these
issues of inclusivity and sustainability
there are ways to invest that take
genuinely takes carbon out of the air
you can do that with a green bond fund
but you cannot do it with these ESG
Equity Funds so so let me let me ask you
what might be a more fundamental
question I mean it seems to me that
anan's um recommendations were
ill-founded a priority and let me walk
through this and tell me what you think
about it
so
because he's making the assumption that
there is already irresponsible
investing that can be rectified by
conscious attention to a set of ethical
principles and see this strikes me as as
ill as an illposed problem because if
you have any sense and you're investing
you invest as wisely as you possibly can
and the reason you all things considered
and the reason you do that is because
well you don't want to lose your money
you're hard-earned money and so you're
already very much motivated to invest
wisely now you could say well that would
open the door to people making a
short-term killing at other people's
expense and maybe that's what happens
with so-called sin investing but my
sense is that well you can get away with
making a short-term investment at other
people's expense once or twice but
you're going to get hammered for it
sooner or later and so anan's notion was
predicated on the idea that there was a
way of imposing an a Priory ethical
framework on the problem of investment
that would produce Investments that
would somehow do better which strikes me
as highly improbable and that would
actually increase what would you say
ethical Behavior as such I would say
that people are already as motivated to
invest wisely as they possibly can be if
they're investing their own money or
money they take stewardship of and the
imposition of some top- down ideological
framework is only going to compromise
the investment strategy and not only the
investment strategy but also the market
strategy of companies I mean look we've
seen well Budweiser is a great example
of an absolute bloody catastrophy Target
put their neck in the same Noose I think
Disney's stock is down something like
50% because they fired everybody who
could actually tell a story and brought
in people who did nothing but you know
produce second rate ideologically
oriented narratives of the sort that
flew in the face of what their customers
demanded and undermined their entire
brand and so how deep do you think the
conflict between the ESG attitude and
the fundamental free market principles
of responsible investing actually runs
because I think like it looks to me that
Anan took what was essentially a
socialist or even a communist view which
is that well the market itself can't be
trusted and it's necess necessary to
generate these a priority ideological
Frameworks because that would direct
everything much more effectively than it
would be otherwise in a you know honest
free market economy the whole thing to
me just strikes first of all there's no
bloody way you're going to beat the
market with the strategy like that
nobody can beat the market not
continuously because they just have all
the money so there is this problem that
it doesn't work in practice but I also
think there's a problem that it doesn't
work in princip iple that it's the wrong
way to go about it it is certainly the
wrong way to go about it so much so that
I have this article that I just shared
with you it's coming out next week with
AI that I co-authored with Senator Phil
Graham where we talk we call for the end
of ESG it's it's an irredeemable project
at this stage Jordan because it is as
you say falsely premised and if
something is falsely premised from the
beginning there there's there's there's
no way to adjust it to to make it work
and you've said something that's very
very wise and you know Warren Buffett
Charlie M recently passed away they've
lived their lives according to this
maximum it is extremely difficult to
beat the S&P 500 you can own it for one
basis point that's what most people
should do but I'm someone you know and
my career has been about advising people
what to do with their with their assets
their Investments and I'm somebody who
deeply believes Jordan that if you're
willing to make an investment that's
going to have a lower return but it's
going to result in I don't you know
affordable housing or it's going to uh
bring clean water to a village in Rwanda
or it's going to and you're willing to
take a lower return my God go at it and
a $ 51 trillion in wealth is about to be
passed from the current generation of
billionaires to their um let's say less
hardworking uh children and that
particular group of individuals are very
mindful for double bottom lines that is
to say they do want their money to do
well and to do good and an important
part part of my new business and all the
work that I'm doing is to provide uh uh
investors who have this double bottom
line mindset that want to do well and do
good that are somehow willing to take a
lower return as long as they somehow
benefit some corner of society well
there's going to be a lot of capital
that's looking to do that and that's
going to be an important part of what
creates this inclusive sustainable
growth world that we're going to need
that's going to be this important this
important part of the community that
that Community you know we said it's the
market it's the state and community that
have to work together and we're going to
need that Community to be part of the
solution so let me let me ask you a
question about that I mean I certainly
understand the the the direction that
you're trying to aim a certain
percentage of investors in and I can
imagine that that would also small
percent a very small percent well and
maybe a percent of someone's portfolio
but I'm also wondering you know like one
of the principles that I've abided by
when a attempting to produce even
products that are
of particular benefit to people
psychologically like I have a suite of
psychological interventions online that
I've been marketing to people for about
two and a half decades I mean one of the
principles that we established my
business partners and I before we
created these um interventions was that
not only did they have to be useful so
to do good not only did they have to
have that they had to be of demonstrable
good but they also had to do
competitively well so if I said well
maybe so so is it too much to ask for
people for example who are providing
affordable housing let's say that they
do it in such a canny manner that they
also equal or beat what you might expect
for standard market returns and couldn't
you use that as an indication of the
quality of their offering or do you do
you feel that there are situations where
placing both constraints on people you
know you have to do good and you have to
do well makes movement forward too
difficult well let let let me give some
numbers to to to frame The Challenge and
and then answer your question directly
so as you probably remember the name of
my company is 1.6
1.6% of institutional assets is $3.5
trillion so this is a little bit like
the bond laurberg number if we actually
if if institutional investors and ultra
high Network individuals were to
allocate 1.6% of their assets per year
to these types of Investments that we're
talking about true double bottomline
Investments affordable housing I can
come up the a number of Health uh
Financial inclusion education there are
any number of booknook is the number of
online learning tools that
are we could actually achieve the United
Nations sustainable development goals by
20130 so that that is the amount of
private Capital that is needed to fill
the Gap so just put that number out
there so you they frame that but let me
respond more specifically to your I
think the the the the one area of
investment that I've spent most my time
on in the United States Jordan is
affordable housing we we are basically
shy I mean we have a homelessness
problem we have a affordable housing
problem there are only three ways really
genuinely to build wealth in a lifetime
one is to start a business or be an
amazing podcaster like yourself two is
to own the S&P 500 for 30 years but the
third one is to own your own home rather
than rent so we need to have find a way
for there to continue to be greater
access to home ownership from those who
right now come out of college with these
student loans and can't make a down
payment we're going to have to find it
it turns out that the equity Returns on
some of these affordable housing
programs in Nashville in Austin uh
across the country the equity returns to
the investors are between 16 and 18% a
year well I'm sorry dear friend that is
still 12% ahead of you know 14 % ahead
of in the inflation rate and well in
line with the Actuarial needs of a
number of the retirees if you can
actually have a 15% return you double
your money every five years who doesn't
want to do that so so so an important
part of what we're doing at my company
is highlighting where these
opportunities for double bottom lines
truly exist it's something that I would
love a future arc form and we're talking
about you know Arc in the United States
having uh it's one that I would like
there to be a thread on in Arc in the
United States because I think the United
States has a far greater likelihood of
leading in philanthropy and leading in
these Creative Solutions than Europe
where they expect governments to do
everything Europe that you know there's
hardly any philanthropic giving in
Europe because everyone well it's the
state you know there's zero
philanthropic G giving in in Russia and
China because the state is the only
thing imagine trying to be a nonprofit
uh in China or or Russia solving
problems you get outlawed so so the the
the very interesting thing though is a
lot of creativity is coming from uh
these various organizations and I always
give a shout out to my dear friend Jim
Sorenson and the senson impact team
which is in Salt Lake City you should
also have Jim senson on at some point so
he pivoted 100% of his portfolio uh
three years ago Jordan to impact the
only types of Investments he makes now
have to have verifiable impact and he's
outperforming the market he's
outperforming the market by 100 now this
to me this is the sweet spot if you're
outperforming the market and you're
solving some major social and
environmental problem of the day I'm all
in I'm all in right right so so you are
making the case that like with
sufficient judgment you can have your
cake and eat it too well that that was
my sense with regards to the stratey
emphasis on emphasis on the sufficient
judgment it's hard you have to be
mindful and there's a lot of Hokum out
there there's a lot of there's a lot of
Pretenders and false gods and
cryptocurrency Trad that have these you
know sols you really must do your
homework to make sure that there is
verifiable additionality that is to say
a dollar that is put into the strategy
is going to create a solution that
absent that dollar does not happen there
needs to be real impact and that's
something that you can say in affordable
housing that's something you can say in
some of these educational initiatives uh
Financial inclusion initiatives uh
improving people's FICO scores for
example gives them direct access to to
to to borrowing and direct and that
there's a whole business Operation Hope
in Atlanta a great NGO one of the one of
the organizations I call an Exemplar of
hope that has a proven pedagogy Jordan a
proven pedagogy that improves
inclusivity and sustainability without
compromising economic growth there are
literally dozens of these organizations
uh throughout the United States and and
a lot of what they're doing can be
replicated around the world so I've kind
of got the you know born lomborg has
done a really good job on these top 12 I
got the next one's down on homelessness
recidivism uh uh job opportunities
here's a great one from Catholic
Charities Fort Worth in Dallas so it
turns out as I'm sure you know 95% of
the community college courses that
people take in the United States of
America which are free basically do not
lead to a certification it turns out a
lot of people taking those Community
College courses it's it's a it's a it's
a crazy waste of money what did they
learn at Catholic Charities Fort Worth
they learned that if they actually give
a casew worker to everyone who's trying
to get a community college degree which
is an expense it's like a BJ laberg cost
benefit expense but if you get that the
completion rates multiply fivefold and
then what happens those mothers then
they're usually single mothers you know
in their teens or early 20s they go from
welfare dependency to to to work in
Independence uh and and and this is
where we where we got to this is what
the call for greater personal
responsibility tells us this is what the
call for for Jacob's letter tells us
this is what the call for greater
inclusivity tells us this is what
Abraham would do if he were alive today
right okay so that that program that you
just described that's something akin to
a mentorship program is so that people
are going to college but they don't have
guidance they don't have any way of of
bouncing their plan off someone and
everyone say know if you have Mom take
care of little Juju on uh on Tuesday
afternoons you can make this course
you're able to make it if you just
adjust your schedule and drop off and
and here's another uh uh daycare program
that could you could use that you
haven't heard of that type of additional
assistance let me give you one though
that I love even more which is teenage
recidivism so it turns out the
laboratory for Economic Opportunity at
the University of Notre Dame which is an
anti-poverty lab studied what was going
on with teenage truants in the state of
Indiana and you know what they found out
Jordan they found out that if they teach
a course of Aristotelian ethics to these
13 14 15 16-year-old kids all of whom
are brighter than we give them credit
for while they are going through these
treny programs recidivism declines
70% the the these these poor children
God bless them have never had anybody to
tell them this is good this is evil this
is this is what an examined life
consists of this is what an unexamined
life results in this is and and and
they're reading the original text
they're reading Aristotle they're
reading Plato you know this uh you know
I was very moved by Oz Guinness for
example uh at at ARK it's the kind of
thing that Oz Guinness would have would
would would would would have designed
himself so when you think of these
individual programs that that I'm
describing another one that I love in
here in New York City is ready willing
and able we're in a we're in a New York
uh Studio here and I'm sure that folks
here have seen there're these guys that
are pushing buckets on the street
corners around New York City and their
job is to sweep up the streets all of
those all of those guys are homeless or
former incarcerates and they're given a
six-month opportunity to decide uh if
they stay clean they stay off of drugs
they they sleep in the home that's are
that are provided to them there's a
communal living circumstance and they
clean the streets for which they are
paid by New York City they can then
choose from more than a dozen
accreditation programs ranging from uh
uh becoming a uh uh a plumber to
becoming a a massage therap IST to any
other and again Jordan they are moved
from dependency to independence from a
life of of of Despair to a life of
meaning fulfillment and purpose and the
the the these are oftentimes funded by
these social bonds that are based on on
on on outcomes the the the the things
that are going on in this sort of social
engineering space social entrepreneurial
space it's very exciting it's very
exciting and something that I hope
future Arc forums will will be able to
you know really put in Bright Lights
Solutions things that are working ways
that we are changing individuals lives
in in in the moment that is verifiably
not only fulfilling them but lowering
the burden on society taking people Reno
Nevada has haved homelessness in the
last six months do you know how Reno
Nevada haved the homeless rate no they
built they built enough affordable
housing and then they made it a law you
cannot sleep on the streets you are
arrested if you stay on the streets so
everybody had a place to go they had to
go to these places guess what happened
when they went to these affordable they
were then given career counseling those
who had drug problems were given uh drug
attention those who are mentally ill and
a good part of our homeless problem in
this country is mentally ill people we
let them ride the subways here it's
crazy no they have to be put into
programs Jordan that actually matches
them with the needs that they have I
don't need to tell you this um uh and
and there there's so Reno Nevada has
done something that San
Francisco uh uh and La need to figure
out uh uh we have more than enough space
in the city of New York to to put
homeless people in fact there's always
enough beds in the city of New York for
for homeless people um but then
combining that with the proper level of
of of training counseling to get to
Independence is what's necessary okay so
so I would like to hear some more of
these Solutions but maybe right now you
could also I'm curious too how are
people how could people who are watching
and listening participate in programs
like this and where could they turn to
for the kind of investment advice into
these programs that you would regard as
credible and reliable yeah yeah so I i'
I've got to be careful here because this
has becomes very self uh self
promotional well that's we can let
people start through that themselves
okay well my my website
www.6.com highlights a whole range of
these investment possibilities and I
have a what I call a curated Town Square
which is called the solutions forum and
on the solutions Forum where I post for
example my video from Arc but any other
is an open source anyone who wants to
put out their ideas for what they're
doing on homelessness what they're doing
on these various social issues are able
to just so that would be one area that I
would suggest an Exemplar of Hope which
is something that I've trademarked is
and it's Global they have a bunch of
these uh there's there's a wonderful uh
one in the UK called make it click which
goes home to home and teaches people how
to use internet services and how to
actually gain access to the information
that's already in their homes that they
didn't know that that that was available
to them make a click program uh these
various exemplars uh have many
opportunities for for for
volunteerism uh for uh other forms of of
uh of of of time uh or talent and
treasure that's what the the
philanthropic world needs time talent
and treasure uh all three are needed um
uh but uh in terms of scaling some of
the very very best ideas I mean anybody
out there wants to volunteer to teach
Aristotelian ethics in their local
delinquency Center there's ways to learn
how to do that and I will promise you
Jordan the people that choose to it's
what you do for a living by the way but
the people who do that will find those
days to the most fulfilling of their
lives the days they're going to come
home and just say I did something today
you said something that I wrote down uh
at the art conference in London which is
that there is no difference between
thinking about ourselves and being
miserable to the extent that we're
focused on ourselves and our own needs
and our wants literally that is the
recipe for human misery you want to
actually be non-m miserable then operate
with the third pillar of of of Catholic
Social teaching which is solidarity we
are our brothers and sisters Keepers uh
and by the way I I I put in that same
category civility I think it's very very
very possible for all of us to
contribute to a greater culture of
Civility uh and and and by the way that
means being better listeners uh as as as
as a as a start and trying to respond to
I've had my niece the one that I worry
about not wanting to have children I
think she's changing her mind come to my
lectures and and read my and just say
please you know Claire criticize me what
did I wrong tell tell me what is did you
have a chance to read this did you see
this um and I can't give up you know I
can't I can't I I can't give up Jordan
it would be wrong for me to give up uh
and it's wrong for any of us to give up
uh Abraham didn't give up did
he so this
1.6.1 n one one is numeric 6 is
alphabetic I also have my own book
sustainable which was endorsed by Pope
Francis and Larry think wrote the
forward that talks about these doz
dozens of these exemplars of Hope just
as examples and also provides this
criticism of the ESG which I'm not going
to leave I believe that we would be
better off just abandoning the whole
project uh moving on acronym based
investing remember the bricks we were
supposed to only invest in the bricks
for a while Brazil Russia India China
well that's not the right investment
strategy then there was the Fang a
Facebook alphabet netfli Google that
made no sense anymore so so we just we
we need to move on from ESG understand
that it was well- intended but that
there's better Solutions there's better
ways for us to achieve greater
inclusivity there's better ways for us
to achieve greater sustainability and I
put it another fine point on this I
think B corporations you probably know B
corporations are these corporations that
promis to operate in very in accordance
with very strict ethical rules very
strict uh environmental rules I say
great working for a b Corporation is
wonderful it leads to a great conscience
just don't have any of those in your
401k because you won't be able to
retire yeah well that well what that
shows is that what what happens is that
the appearance of moral effort is
substituted for actual moral effort and
that's why those companies underperform
like what one of the things we should
point out to people who are watching and
listening in keeping with what you just
said is that there is no magic bullet to
invest it is no simpler to invest your
money than it is to earn it those are
equivalent problems and you have to be
one wise and awake person to figure out
where to put your money so that it will
generate a return and that's probably
the first thing you should be looking
for because if the people who are who
have your money can't do that they
probably can't do anything else and then
the second thing you should consider is
well is this the sort of Enterprise that
you believe in your soul is worth
supporting because you're actually
morally obligated to do wise things with
your money as well well not least to
demonstrate to yourself that you have
some respect for the time and effort you
invested into generating the money to
begin with and I suppose not least
because poorly invested money can do an
awful lot of damage right the last thing
you want to do is give dangerous idiots
money I I need to give you an amen a
double amen a triple Amen on all of that
and just maybe add for listeners that we
think a lot about our physical health we
think a lot about our emotional health
we think a lot about our mental health
we we go to the gym we're careful with
what we eat we need to be equally
mindful about our Financial Health
particularly in this age of Aging almost
everyone listening to this podcast uh is
going to uh end up outliving their
parents uh and they're going to be there
in their 80s
not and if all they have is Social
Security they do not have a meaningful
life you're going to have to have some
type of Nest Egg we are living longer
and I'm saying this to everybody in the
room as well what you have to do with
your 401k is put it in the stock market
when you're young and forget about it
don't even look at it until you turn 65
when you turn 65 you're going to open
and say wow I've got $2 million in
savings how did I do that you did it by
not bothering with it you just let it go
be mindful about your savings patterns
be mindful about your investment
patterns if you are so wealthy and you
have so much time and you want to go for
double bottom line investing or you have
a desire to have your money do well and
do good well that's fine too but it's
still going to ire mindfulness it's
still going to require deep care it's
still going to require discernment
because there's no easy way to just like
you have to be careful about your uh
physical health you have to be care
careful about your Financial Health yeah
well I studied for a while the
phenomenon of money managers because I
was interested in investigating the
possibility that there were statistical
ways of predicting Market behavior and I
basically concluded not that this was
unique to me but at least to my own
satisfaction that that was was actually
a technically impossible outcome to
perform except in very rare cases and so
that your best bet and this is the
advice that you gave earlier is if
you're especially if you're the average
investor is to buy something like an
index fund with a low manager fee and
just leave it the hell alone because
you're not going to beat you're not
going to beat that now um let me give
you a statistic for that only one out of
five managers beats the S&P 500 uh over
a 5year period only one out of 10 over a
10-e period and they aren't the same
manager right they aren't the same
manager precisely so so so so the idea
that somehow you're smart enough oh I'm
going to buy Netflix and Google and hang
on to it and see what I can it's nuts
you cannot be smarter than the market
something so easy you can buy for one
basis point at Vanguard Fidelity any
number of places and just put it in
place and forget it and the older you
get start buying some bonds and having
an income stream uh and then but more
importantly volunteer your time look
after your community be involved with
those in need around you be there for
your brothers and sisters your grandkids
and others that's where you're going to
want to spend your time right right
right now you said that you had that
Larry thinkink wrote the intro to your
book and that's interesting because
Larry think is probably the world's most
famous proponent of the ESG strategy and
so how how did that come about and um
well I I presume you you obviously must
know Larry and what does he think of
your uh your ideas and why did he write
the forward to your
book well this is how many people are
listening to this podcast Jordan because
this is quite a personal story oh
somewhere between 350,000 and a
million um but but know I'm G to tell
the story I'm gon to tell I'm gonna I'm
going to tell the story it's a story
worth telling and it reflects very well
on Larry think and and my colleagues at
Black Rock so I was a very senior
executive Black Rock um I went to the
group executive board I said I wanted to
write this book on ESG I didn't know
where it was going to take me Jordan ESG
was a relatively new thing uh I I I
wanted to spend time I I didn't have my
my ideas so forly as I went into the
book and as I started studying all these
ESG ratings and the fact that they're
completely uncorrelated and frankly
they're a bunch of nonsense they they
made no sense I ended up becoming more
critical of what was coming out on on
ESG and I'm still submitting all of
these chapters to my colleagues in
Columbia University press columia is the
my publisher and I'm thinking that I'm
uh you know huny Dory on my way well it
turns out when the book finished my uh
senior Executives at Black Rock said you
can't publish this book this this book
is a little too uh racy I said well I'm
I'm I'm I'm I'm sorry I I think that we
agreed that that that we would well go
speak to the boss so I went to speak to
Larry and um I said Larry Larry go and
he said this is very simple I have a
simple solution I'll write the forward
to the book and what does Larry write in
the forward to the book I I commend it
to you he's very complimentary of me
he's very uh complimentary of the work
that I do the book but says I don't
agree with everything Terry says so very
simple very simple you know get out of
jail and Larry to his great credit and I
have nothing but great things to say
about Larry think he is a close friend
always welcom the debate today Larry
think does not use the term ESG he has
tricken it from his vocabulary because
he's decided it is overly politicized
and it means the the wrong thing it's
not so I would say I I probably get some
credit for that you know uh Larry
think's not using ESG you know one down
four billion to go um uh let's focus on
impact investing let's F focus on true
double bottom line and let's focus on
making sure that asset owners those who
investors get what they really want I
mean I advise the pope uh you know on
finances uh advised the world's largest
Sovereign wealth funds I always only ask
one question Jordan what are you trying
to do if I if I were your financial
adviser I would do the same thing what
are you Jordan Peterson trying to do
what are your goals lay it out give me
your plan what's what what what are you
trying to do and then it is my fiduciary
duty to make sure that I devise the most
coste effective efficient and highest
probability portfolio solution that will
actually achieve what your goals are
that's what being a fiduciary means and
I can say with my heart uh my hand on my
heart that in the 13 years that I was at
Black Rock I never did anything but that
I never sold a single ESG fund when I
was at Black Rock and I did more than
$130 trillion worth of transactions
which is a lot of transactions uh and
never once sold an ESG fund because they
were never the right solution they were
never the right solution you you you
said that you had you had worked with
Pope Francis and I've been struck and I
would say primarily negatively by what
I've seen as his emphasis on climate
responsibility let's say my sense is
that the proper responsibility of the
church is the Salvation of individual
souls and that that sort of thing is
contentious and political enough so that
it's actually not the proper business of
the church now I don't know much about
po Pope Francis
and apart from that particular criticism
I would say and my the small knowledge
that was required to generate it I'm
quite ignorant would you tell me and
your viewer and our viewers um what your
experience was in working with Pope
Francis on such uh on such ideas um and
and I I would I will do so with joy um I
always say you know uh uh Jordan that my
Catholic church has the heart of Pope
Francis the brains of Benedict V 16th
and the fortitude of John Paul II and it
turns out those three individuals didn't
agree on a lot uh and Pope Francis is
someone who uh has definitely veered
into a number of economic and social
topics that I do not personally agree
with but having been a Catholic all 64
years of my life I note that the
church's teachings evolve let me tell
you though a personal story about Pope
Francis uh so during the time that I was
working on this Vatican Financial Reform
Commission I lived in the exact same
residence where he lived which is Santa
Marta within uh at the Vatican City
State and every morning I was allowed to
go to mass and one morning uh I was at
mass and there was a just a horrible
smell and I couldn't figure out what
this horrible smell was this is a fairly
curated audience and I look over my my
right shoulder and I see there's a
homeless guy with two dogs right behind
me and I'm thinking to myself well you
know security was a little lack today
not sure how this happened um uh so we
go out to to breakfast and breakfast at
at Santa Marta is served a cafeteria
style so the pope is helping himself to
eggs just as you're leaning over for a
piece of bacon and you're smiling with
one another and it's a very cordial
Affair but I sat down I said you know um
uh there was some people in the back of
the chapel this morning does anybody
know what's going oh yeah you don't know
he said no I don't know I said well yes
every night Pope Francis sends one of
his emissaries out to the bridges in
Rome and finds homeless people and
invites them to come to mass the next
morning he they usually do that between
11: and 1:00 in the morning 11:00 p.m.
1:00 in the morning and this particular
individual said well I'd like to come
but I can't because I have two dogs and
they said you're allowed to bring the
dogs so this person was the personal
invit invitee of Pope Francis to come
and hear the word of the Lord by the way
he was also given a shower a shampoo and
a shave at the end of it uh Pope Francis
instituted in the Vatican City State a
free barber shop for anybody in Rome who
wants to come in and get cleaned up
that's paid for by by by the Vatican so
I think this is a story that I hope uh
you know reveals the heart of Pope
Francis who is a good man I don't know
about you Jordan but being in charge of
1.2 billion Souls on the planet that's
one hell of a burden being in charge of
a of an organization that is as
political as as as the church is with as
wide views politically as as you can
possibly imagine from from uh Liberation
theologists who are full-blown marxists
to some of the most conservative people
on the planet all of those people are
Catholics Under One Roof uh uh to
actually try to be the shepherd for that
flock is not a task that I envy and I'll
also just point out that there are only
three monarchies left on the planet uh
Pope francis's is one of them Crown
Prince Muhammad bin Salon of Saudi
Arabia is another and the Sultan of
brunai what these three guys say goes in
their country whatever they do that's
the law and so the uh uh heavy is the
head that bears the crown heavy is the
head that bears the pontiff uh uh hat
and um my my my respect for Pope Francis
and what he's trying to do is eternal uh
I respectfully disagree with him on
things but the Catholic Church like
every Church like any any listener
believer it's it's it's the the
community of Believers that ultimately
make that Community there is such a
thing as the congregation of the Le the
Le within the Catholic church has a lot
to say uh and those of us who have
disagreements with church I'm writing
this article with Erica castelow right
now on the issue of of of children Erica
by the way another wonderful speaker uh
at the art conference in London somebody
I had dinner with two nights ago with
her husband and um uh we believe that we
can push the church a little bit further
we should not have unwanted children
Jordan we should not bring being
bringing people into this world that we
cannot properly take care of if that
involves some form of birth control will
so be it uh and so we're going to have
to have more of a grown-up conversation
inspired by the teachings of Jesus
inspired by the teachings of the church
that that that takes into account that
we live in this new world of 10 billion
people 10 billion people trying to make
this little ball of and water and a
little little little sliver of air on
top of it work for centuries and
centuries to come because like Abraham
we have to care about our great great
great great
grandchildren well you know that's a
pretty good place to end and it's
perfectly timed so I think we'll take
that opportunity to do exactly that I'm
going to reiterate for the viewers and
listeners the websites that you
described the first one was
www. 1.6 . with one numeric and six
written out I've got that right I hope
and point is also written out one one is
numeric point is written out p o i n TS
ix.com okay okay and you you talked
about the solutions for there you also
mentioned a site in the UK U makeit
click.com if I got that right we'll put
all this in the description of the
video speaker notes yes absolutely
absolutely so um well thank you very
much for discussion today uh cleared up
a lot of things for me I was very
particularly curious about your comments
about Larry Fink and I'm I'm very glad
to hear that he had the largess of Mind
of spirit let's say to to uh
enthusiastically promote your book
despite the fact that you had
substantive disagreements with him I
thought you did a a remarkable job of
being evenhanded in your discussion of
the ESG movement pointing out that you
know it's a mistake to assume that the
motivations that gave rise to the to the
movement
were all to be treated with cynicism
exactly yeah well and I think the same
thing is true of the UN Millennium goals
I mean the we need Ambitions and we need
to figure out how to implement them
without undo top- down control and
that's actually a very difficult problem
right it's something we're wrestling
with at ARC is like well how can we
provide leadership without d d what
transforming across even a few short
years into just another organization
that issues top down you know moral
pronouncements it's very difficult thing
to get right for any length of time so I
appreciate all that um I want to thank
everybody who's watching and listening
for your time and attention I repeat
that after every episode but it's always
true I'm I'm very thrilled to have the
privilege to talk to as many people as I
do get to talk to and I'm also heartened
by the fact that these podcasts which
are very technically complex and that I
what put forward at the highest level of
my intellectual ability that they meet
with such a receptive audience and that
all these people like you sir who can
bring their wisdom out into the world
are being welcomed in their attempts to
do so I think that's absolutely
remarkable and and another reason for
Hope in a in a in a future that's going
to be very challenging but that is Rife
with an unbelievable amount of
opportunities which is also something
that you made clear today so and thank
you again to the dailywire plus people
for making these conversations possible
in the film crew here in on Vancouver
Island where I am with my family um I'm
going to continue my discussion with
Terry on The Daily we plus platform I'd
like to delve a little bit into his
personal background find out I want to
find out where he came from and why and
what motivates him and so if you want to
join us on the daily Weare plus side
that also offers you an opportunity to
throw some support the daily wire way
and I think that's a useful thing to do
given what they're attempting to
accomplish in the world there's a
organization that's trying to do good
and do well at the same time and my
experience with them really indicates
that that is what they're attempting to
do and quite successfully so hopefully
we'll join some of you there thanks
again Mr key much much appreciated it's
an honor Jordan genuinely an honor thank
you so much for having
[Music]
me